Mangroves are some of
the most diverse habitats
on the planet.
These coastal forests which
have adapted to live in
constantly changing saltwater
tides are home to sharks,
manatees and tigers.
But people depend on mangroves too.
So far, the protection
offered to coastal areas
hasn't been enough of an incentive
to save this precious ecosystem.
In the decade up to 2020, the
area of mangroves decreased
by over one million hectares globally.
This is especially
troubling in West Africa,
where 80% of the population
live on the Atlantic Coast.
Rising sea levels have
caused widespread erosion
and flooding in low lying areas.
While rising temperatures and drought
accelerate the evaporation of
water and increase salinity,
killing off mangroves.
Senegal has been hit particularly hard,
losing a third of its mangrove forest
between 1950 and the early 2000s.
In a village at the mouth
of the Senegal River,
1,500 people have
already been moved inland
to makeshift camps.
Authorities have warned
that at least 15,000 people
are at risk of being displaced
as rising sea levels flood homes,
mosques and agricultural land.
In a village called Djiffer,
inhabitants have already seen
most of their mangrove forest disappear
while the coast continues to erode.
In an effort to avoid more flooding,
inhabitants of Djiffer are
taking drastic measures
such as rolling giant
boulders into the sea
to act as barriers against
the rising sea levels.
Some communities are
taking other action too
and replanting their
lost mangrove forests.
They could store up to 7 times more carbon
than terrestrial forests,
reducing climate change
and protect villages from
coastal erosion and flooding.
They could also offer residents
greater economic benefits
than they've ever had before.
Mangroves are food factories.
The roots provide a surface that oysters
and other mollusks can
colonize and grow on.
And the complex structure
of meandering channels
offers a sanctuary to many
different kinds of fish.
For centuries, in villages
like Dassilame Serere,
people had relied on the mangroves
to harvest oysters and other seafood.
As the forest disappeared,
so too did this way of life.
But following a grant
from the United Nations,
the community have been able
to replant their forests
and begin farming again.
Slowly but surely, the
forests have grown back.
And the community also made other changes
to make sure both mangroves
and oysters would thrive.
The workers put stakes
with thin ropes in the mud
for the oysters to latch onto.
This reduces pressure on
the remaining mangroves,
and lets the oysters grow bigger.
Farmers can now sell fresh
oysters to local seaside resorts
or can them for a much higher profit
than they ever could before.
All around the young mangroves,
the villagers have seen
the return of fish,
crabs and other species
that had disappeared.
It's something that could be
replicated all over the world
as a tool to help communities
while global efforts are
made to fight climate change.